avec nous pour en débattre louis georges
tin militants et essayiste bonsoir avoue
christian bourdeilles à vos côtés
président du souvenir napoléonien
bonsoir à tous les deux messieurs merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt fons
regarder notre histoire en francs en
phase 1 c'est ce qu'a dit emmanuel
macron dans son premier discours avant
l'hommage aux invalides hommage dont 100
célébration on a bien précisé
du côté de l'elysée il a trouvé le ton
juste emmanuel macron pour vous
christian bourdeilles en tant que
président du souvenir vous êtes restés
sur notre faim
écoutez moi je suis satisfait des propos
du président il se devait d'être modéré
dans ses propos faire la part des choses
moi je retiens une expression puisque
j'ai eu la chance d'être à l'institut
est de pouvoir l'écouter en direct pour
moi c'était un grand moment on
l'attendait aussi pas simplement ceux
qui sont critiques mais aussi ceux qui
sont plutôt favorables donc à cet
héritage et ce qu'il a dit là dire où
nous avons renoncé au pire de lempire et
omeyer de l'empereur va écouter je pense
que c'était cet exercice difficile qu'il
fallait faire mais moi je globalement je
suis satisfait rien de désagréable
entendre a été dit bon ça manquait
peut-être un petit peu de souffle parce
que quand même l'épopée des napoléonien
c'est une grande épopée qui très
romantique aussi
jongle
sas a manqué un petit peu mais je vous
le dis en tant que président du souvenir
napoléonien qui espère toujours un peu
plus peut-être de légende dorée et je
hais la légende dorée le roman national
moi je l'assumé totalement parce que il
est constitutif de ce que nous sommes et
nous sommes là aussi pour essayer de
rêver au destin de la france
et quand on rêve au dessin de la france
on s'appuie notamment sur l'épopée
intériale louis georges tin le même avis
vous voilà on imagine que vous étiez
plutôt critique et puis on attend
peut-être face à ce discours
quel est votre sentiment ce soir il faut
rappeler que la cohésion est associé à
trois crimes majeurs un crime politique
le coup d'état du 18 brumaire des crimes
de guerre et contre l'humanité de
rétablissement des esclavages par
conséquent il faut l'enseigner car c'est
un personnage très important mais lui
rendre un hommage déposer une fleur
devant sa tombe de par une chose à digne
et monsieur macro va dans cinq jours
célébrer l'abolition des esclavages
après avoir célébré celui qu'il avait
rétabli le en même temps a quand même
des limites
je trouve que c'est quelque chose
effectivement absolument insupportable
et il est le président qui divise
il fallait marquer des choses on pouvait
faire une exposition c'est très bien
enseigner oui mais pourquoi est il
besoin de s'y rendre
voilà la question que je pose et je
trouve qu'il s'est rendu hadid ou de la
célébration qui aura lieu dans cinq
jours
indigne d'une célébration c'est le en
même temps qu'il ne passe pas christian
bourdeilles quelle est votre réponse
alors moi c'est pour assurer mon
interlocuteur que je n'ai pas la chance
de voir alors je le rassure parce que
les célébrations où les la commémoration
ne se termine pas ce soir et vous savez
qu'il ya quand même le projet de pendre
un cheval en plastique au dessus du
tombeau de l'empereur et tout ça pour y
parait t'il ré humaniser la figure de
l'empereur napoléon 1er donc je rassure
totalement dominateur locuteurs la
tentation de dénigrer de rabaisser la
figure de l'empereur
va va bientôt apparaître encore une fois
par ce projet de pendre un cheval en
plastique au dessus du tombeau de
l'empereur qui est pour moi quelque
chose là pour le coup je reprend les
mêmes termes qui est particulièrement
intolérable et je ne comprends pas
d'ailleurs que le président de la
république pour le coup est autorisée
donc cette oeuvre dit-on artistique je
respecte toutes les oeuvres artistiques
bien évidemment mais pendre un cheval en
plastique qui normalement doit
correspondre au cheval de
mme arago que napoléon aurait abandonné
à waterloo ce qui d'ailleurs
complètement faux sur le plan historique
ça c'est quelque chose qui est tout à
fait désagréable donc et j'espère que ce
projet n'ira pas jusqu'au bout donc en
tout cas s'il va jusqu'au bout mon
interlocuteur peut être complètement
rassuré donc là dénigration donc de
l'empereur est bien aussi au programme
est encore au programme
même si encore une fois je l'espère ce
projet n'ira pas jusqu'au bout avant de
vous faire réagir lui les gens rejetant
voudrais vous faire écouter un premier
saut emmanuel macron on n'a pas encore
entendu un et napoléon pour lui et une
part de nous écouter napoléon bonaparte
est une part de nous parce que l'action
et les leçons du guerrier du stratège du
législateur autant que du bâtisseur
porte encore c'est ce qu'a notre siècle
oui georges tin quand vous entendez le
président dira napoléon est une part de
nous vous vous sentez quand même un
petit peu concernée ou pas du tout alors
c'est une part d'histoire de france est
contestable le mans mais encore une fois
il confond célébrer et enseigner qui
fait dans signaux wi le cil brinon
rendre un hommage
moi je dis comment vont à nouveau faire
france lorsque les héros d un sur les
bourreaux des autres et on a eu le même
débat en france il n'ya pas très
longtemps finalement il ya quelques
décennies sur pétain certains disaient
oui il faut quand même commémorer pétant
a pas le célébrer on voit bien
l'hypocrisie de ce genre de formules la
dernière rue pétain en france a été
enlevée il y à peu près 20 ans donc
c'est ce même débat qui meurent en
france à l'espagne par exemple sur
franco lui aussi est un général caf un
coup d'état
eh bien les espagnols après un débat
national ont eu le courage de dire il
faut rendre la dépouille de franco à sa
famille et à la place du tombeau
monumental qui lui étaient accordées
faire un bus et non je pense que
pareille aux aveugles il faudrait faire
un billet de l'histoire des républiques
pourquoi pas
on parle beaucoup de valeurs
républicaines et en même temps on
célèbre le fossoyeur de la république
moi je dis façon business park 402
république dans l'histoire ça vaudrait
le coup d'être enseignée et rendons
respectueusement le corps de napoléon à
sa famille parce que ce n'est pas à la
république de financer le tombeau du
fossoyeur de la république question
bourdeilles c'est vrai qu'on n'imagine
vous n'êtes pas du même avis est ce que
l'on m'a justement à napoléon et qu'il
en danger aujourd'hui c'est vrai que et
on n'avait pas rendu hommage au
président n'avait pas rendu hommage
depuis georges pompidou façade afin 1969
vous admettez que ça peut devenir
compliqué
je comprends pas forcément que ça veut
dire compliqué que qu'on fasse de
l'histoire moi ça me dérange pas du tout
au contraire
et encore une fois comme le président de
la république l'a bien dit il ya des
zones d'ombré et faisant de l'histoire
mais faisons l'histoire c'est à dire il
faut pas juger a priori et j'espère que
les enseignants donc justement donc de
la république prenne le temps donc de
regarder qu'elle est l'oeuvre de
napoléon encore moi je reviens toujours
au code civil
le code civil que les révolutionnaires
n'ont pas été capables de mettre au
point ces le premier consul qui l'a mis
au point ce code civil qui règle tous
pleins de vie de la naissance à la mort
c'est pas rien ça et je suis désolé
encore une fois sont pas les
révolutionnaires alors comparé
maintenant napoléon au maréchal pétain
je vous rappelle quand même que françois
mitterrand homme de gauche je crois
déposés chaque année donc une gerbe de
fleurs sur la tombe du maréchal pétain
alors heureusement aujourd'hui on a
arrêté sa mai
je pense que l'occasion du bicentenaire
de la mort de l'empereur napoléon 1er il
fallait quand même rendre hommage cet
empereur il est connu dans le monde
entier
tout le monde le connaît à travers le
monde vous dessinez le chapeau de
napoléon tout le monde sait que c'est
napoléon bonaparte et quoi qu'on en dise
c'est l'homme de la révolution c'est lui
qui a fait que la révolution française
s'étant créés de manière définitive dans
notre histoire
alors je sais bien que ça peut déplaire
ça peut poser problème mais c'est quand
même d'une certaine façon la faillie de
la révolution française dans ses débuts
et heureusement que le premier consul
donc a rétabli l'ordre la liberté et
surtout donc l'espoir parce que c'était
aussi l'espoir de pouvoir vivre dans de
meilleures conditions
et encore une fois le patch est lauréat
le dac que nos enfants vont bientôt
passer
je suis désolé le bac c'est napoléon les
lycées c'est napoléon
donc c'est comme pas mal du tout a donc
d'avoir un chef d'état qui s'intéressait
beaucoup donc à l'éducation dont des
enfants
mais encore une fois il faut pas
regarder napoléon bonaparte avec nos
yeux de 2021
il faut faire de l'histoire pour regarde
exactement comment les choses se sont
passées george washington
donc à des plus de 200 esclaves on n'a
pas des bêtises et la capitale des
etats-unis pour autant donc encore une
fois il faut faire la part des choses et
je reconnais encore une fois la qualité
du discours du président de la
république de ce côté là était tout à
fait intéressant est que moi j'avais
accepte
entier encore une fois il ya des départs
dont comme n'importe quel parcours
y compris des grands révolutionnaires
leppard ombre de de fidel castro de che
guevara de lénine bas ça existe aussi
donc regardons tous à et faisons pas une
fixation sur cette part d'ombré de
l'empereur un jour je les reconnais bien
évidemment et quand on voit toute
l'oeuvre donc de napoléon c'est que
c'est vraiment très vraiment grandiose
christian bouteilles en va écouter
justement à ce qu'audi emmanuel macron
lui même face aux critiques notamment à
gauche à cette décision de commémorer
écouter au fond de lempire nous avons
renoncé au pire et de l'empereur nous
avons un bel hymne aux meilleurs
commémorer ce bicentenaire
c'est dire cela simplement sereinement
sans céder jamais à la tentation du
procès anachronique qui consisterait à
juger le passé avec les lois du présent
justement louis georges tin sur cet
aspect ne pas céder à la tentation du
procès est anachronique vous l'attendez
ça au président de la république parce
que comme nous l'a dit christ en
bouteille c'est un personnage qui
fascine jusqu'au au delà de nos
frontières
quelques fois fascinant c'est un constat
évident mais ce n'est pas avec les yeux
d'aujourd'hui qu'on le juge puisque déjà
à l'époque évidemment déjà été choqués
je rappelle que l'esclavagé avait aboli
en 1794
donc lorsque napoléon le rétabli c'est
un scandale pas seulement pour les
esclaves mais pour beaucoup de français
de l'époque
par ailleurs quand on parle de pardon
brrr je suis extrêmement choqué par ces
formules qui vise à effet misé au crime
contre l'humanité n'est pas une pardon
excusez moi c'est une manière de dire en
gros c'est un petit détail c'est une
ombre au tableau
mais non ce n'est pas une embauche c'est
un crime contre lui même
voilà il faut vraiment dire des choses
et je pense que c'est mépriser les
grandes parties non seulement des noirs
de france
mais tous les gens qui sont humanistes
quelle que soit leur couleur seront
choqués comme moi que l'on dise cette
part d'ombré
en fait c'est secret quand humanité donc
on peut pas dire ça par ailleurs je
voudrais rappeler que même les acquis
que le chante lee laudateurs de nos
produits dont du point de vue des
territoires la france est beaucoup plus
petit qu'à nullité avant le coup d'état
on perd donc que la louisiane qui
représentent 20% des états unis ça
dingue bien entendu mascaret etc
donc même quelqu'un qui est nationaliste
de rester c'est une catastrophe
ensuite le code civil en réalité repose
sur la ségrégation raciale puisque
napoléon précise que les droits ne
seront pas les mêmes selon la couleur de
peau de contenu dit c'est une merveille
jeudi c'est une merveille de racisme du
temps lorsqu'on me dit par exemple il a
fait la banque de france je dis oui
c'est une grande banque qui est fondée
sur des acquis négrier les trois quarts
des fondateurs la banque de france qui à
l'époque est tellement privés sont des
négriers des armateurs
donc voyez le bien qui fit il le fit mal
le mal qu'il fit il le fit bien votre
réponse à sa question beauté
écoutez le problème de l'esclavagé est
un problème beaucoup plus vaste
il a il a duré pendant de nombreuses
années il existait avant d'un napoléon
bonaparte
pendant des siècles et des siècles
vous reproche absolument pas aujourd'hui
aux sultans ottomans d'avoir été des
esclavagistes
monsieur erdogan aujourd'hui en turquie
veut donc faire renaître l empire
ottoman la pression de l'escalavage
personne ne lui en parle bien évidemment
quand vous savez la traite donc a existé
pendant de nombreuses années
donc entre les pays du moyen orient et
les pays africains
je crois que justement c'est l'honneur
donc de l'europe occidentale avoir posé
le problème la preuve c'est qu'on en
parle aujourd'hui j'aimerais bien qu'on
en parle de la même façon en turquie et
dans les pays du moyen-orient et y
compris donc en afrique car on sait très
bien que commencer s'est effectuée cet
esclavage qui était je reconnais bien
évidemment un crime contre l'humanité
devrait revenir quand on dit ben on en a
vendu la louisiane oui effectivement moi
je suis pas un colonialiste donc la
louisiane c'est très bien qu'elle était
vendue donc aux états unis bien
évidemment quant aux autres possessions
heureusement que napoléon n'a pas été un
colonialiste parce que le pouvoir le
plus colonialiste et quand même la
république française donc de ce côté là
moi je regrette rien bien évidemment et
je suis pas regretter je suis pas
nationaliste encore une fois moi je veux
qu'on fasse de l'histoire moi je suis à
la tête d'une société historique
s'appelle souvenir napoléonien et ont
fait de l'histoire on regarde les choses
et c'est ça qui est intéressant en
faisant l'histoire moi je suis pas là
pour cacher les choses
encore une fois napoléon aboli la traite
en 1815 c'est quand même lui napoléon à
libérer les esclaves à malte en egypte y
compris sa politique de libération donc
des juifs dans toute l'europe grâce
justement à ces idées de potes civile
donc vous vous demandez donc donc lui
faisait toute l'europe aujourd'hui vous
diront que c'est napoléon qui a libéré
le ghetto de berlin le ghetto de
varsovie qui existait déjà à cette
époque là c'est un libérateur c'est que
l'on veuille ou non
encore une fois il n'a peut-être pas
tout réussi le il faut la part des
choses cette wii et emmanuel macron
lui-même n'a pas occulté cette zone dont
je vous propose justement de l'écouter
sur le thème de l'esclavagé
napoléon en 1802 vous l'avez là aussi
évoqué a rétabli l'esclavagé que la
convention de 1794 avait aboli en 1848
avec victor schoelcher la deuxième
république à réparer cette faute
cette trahison de l'esprit des lumières
c'était quand même très attendu louis
georges tin notamment dans les dom tom
où il ya plein de descendants d'esclaves
il ne s'est pas caché pour le coup
emmanuel macron il à une courageuse bien
voilà c'était une faute
vous appréciez quand même justement
cette partie c'est pas vraiment un
courage n'avait pas le choix
la vérité c'est que pendant très
longtemps la géographie autour de nos
pollutions à cacher cela il a fallu dix
historiens très courageux pour dire la
vérité et qui était insulté au départ on
leur disait vous crachez sur la polio
disait mais je fait que rappeler les
faits donc si aujourd'hui le président
rappelle les faits c'est parce qu'il ya
eu des gens des historiens qui se sont
battus pour faire reconnaître cette
vérité qui était vraiment caché de déjà
il faut le noter donc il faut rendre
justice aux personnes qui ont fils de
travail et puis deuxièmement moi je lui
dis quand on est le pays des droits de
l'homme on ne peut pas être en même
temps deux pays qui célèbre les gens qui
dénoncent qui violent les droits de
l'homme
il ya un moment il faut avoir un peu de
cohérence un peu de dignité
donc c'est pour cela que je dis on ne
peut pas rendre hommage à l'auteur de
très contre l'humanité c'est un petit
peu comme la question du détail de
l'histoire
on se rappelle monsieur le pen qui nous
disait bon bien sûr il ya eu la shoah
c'est un détail de l'histoire
alors quand on me dit napoléon les
formidables après il ya eu quelques
petites pardon je trouve que ça
ressemble un peu et ce n'est pas très
digne donc arrêtons avec ce vocabulaire
de la part d'ombré
appelons un chat un chat déjà à l'époque
des révolutionnaires disait que c'est un
crime de lèse humanité que de fers
d'esclaves âge ce n'est pas d'hier matin
que date cette incrimination
donc aujourd'hui je le dis si on veut
véritablement créer de l'unité dans ce
pays il faut choisir des héros qui sont
rassembleur ce n'est pas le cas de
napoléon à l'évidence de la preuve on se
débat nous avons quantité d'hommes et de
femmes héroïques dans ce pays on touche
à choisir d'autres
pourquoi choisir celui là simplement
parce qu'ils flattent si vous voulez la
volonté de puissance héroïsme facile et
clinquants et on se fiche finalement du
droit de la liberté des valeurs
républicaines
je trouve que ce n'est pas 10 merci en
tout cas à tous les deux nous oui
georges temps question bourdeilles à ne
mettra pas d'accord mais c'était ça la
richesse de ce face-à-face merci à vous
d'avoir été en direct sur rt fonce